[Musique]
notre enquête sur les civilisations
perdues s'appuie sur de très anciennes
constructions dont la réalisation n'est
pas possible à égal et même de nos jours
[Musique]
cela signifie t'il que l'homme était
jadis très évolué et qu'il est en
régression
[Musique]
pour le savoir nous allons fouiller dans
la nuit des temps les plus anciennes
réalisations attribué à la main de
l'homme et qui puisse être datés ne
remonte qu'à la dernière période du
paléolithique
il y a environ vingt mille ans quand les
hommes commencent à s'intéresser aux
mystères de la vie après la mort aux
amulettes magique des chamans et aux
orientations solstice yal représenté par
les mégalithes
[Musique]
ce ne sont sûrement pas ces hommes des
cavernes qui ont bâti les énormes
construction en pierre qui émerveille
encore nos ingénieurs
[Musique]
il y a environ 4500 ans elles avaient
stupéfié les hommes de l'âge du bronze
[Musique]
à cette époque un peuple venant
d'anatolie fonde sur l'île de crète
la première civilisation européenne le
roi minos est un sage conseiller par une
caste sacerdotale dont la tâche est de
percer le voile de ce passé lointain
n'ayant aucun moyen technique ils font
alors confiance à leur expérience
mystique et donne naissance à
l'ésotérisme un culte du savoir secret
transmis entre initiés
d'après ces visionnaires du plus petit
organisme à la nature tout entière tout
est conçu comme un être vivant
obéissant aux mêmes lois de l'univers et
ils appellent dieu des mystères les
maîtres des phénomènes impossible à
comprendre
[Musique]
au fil du temps des pratiques
ésotériques liés aux dieux des mystères
apparaissent partout dans le monde
telles que le culte rendu à la déesse
égyptienne des morts isis à la déesse
mère turque si belle aux dieux hindous
iranien mitra devenu ensuite un dieu
romain et à tant d'autres divinités
[Musique]
dans la grèce antique le culte
ésotérique le plus important est celui
des mystères d'eleusis
pratiquée dans le temple de demeter à et
le this pas loin d'athènes ce culte est
consacrée aux divinités de la terre et
du monde souterrain
l'ésotérisme grecque est également
pratiquée par dionysos orphée et
pythagore des mystiques que vêtus de
blanc et au régime alimentaire
végétarien
[Musique]
quelques siècles c'est cool et d'autres
cultes ésotérique sont pratiquées dans
le monde tels la cabale du judaïsme le
nirvana indien tibétains japonais et le
soufisme de l'islam
[Musique]
ainsi parmi les rites les oracles les
nombres les symboles les visions les
anges les esprits
la magie
[Musique]
l'alchimie l'illumination et tout ce qui
est dans le cadre du mystère des maîtres
spirituels appelé maj transmettent aux
disciples un savoir qui doit rester
secret
[Musique]
au moyen-âge dans tu écris l'énigmatique
divine comedy et les troubadours
chantent des poèmes ésotérique sur
l'alchimie l'oracle le graal et
l'astrologie
pendant la renaissance l'ésotérisme est
à la base de l'hermétisme italien de
marsile ficin de la kabbale chrétienne
de pic de la mirandole et de la
théosophie chrétienne de paracelse
[Musique]
depuis 1600 l'ésotérisme et ses secrets
sont représentés par l'illuminisme la
rose-croix le néo druidisme la franc
maçonnerie le martinisme mystique judéo
chrétien le tarot divinatoire
le néo occultisme la société
théosophique de carl gustav jung
l'anthroposophie de rudolf stener qui
aborde les questions spirituelles des
religions et le perennia l'isthme de
rené guénon qui suit les traditions
initiatique authentique
[Musique]
de nos jours les hôtes et rythme est
pratiqué par les médecines alternatives
l'école de bulgarie le nez au catharisme
le néo chamanisme la new age
la psychologie transpersonnelle et la
magie du chaos
cette dernière utilisant les états
d'inhibition de la conscience appelée
clause qui utilisent la méditation
le chant la danse la drogue la douleur
et l'orgasme
pour percer les mystères de la création
[Musique]
après cet aperçu non exhaustif de
l'ésotérisme
intéressons nous à ces enseignements
pour le moins étonnant d'après la
culture ésotérique l'histoire du monde
commence il y a quatre cent mille ans
avec l'apparition de grandes
civilisations vadi par un genre
humanoïde qui n'était pas l'homme actuel
en effet des énigmes sont posées par les
différents groupes sanguins et surtout
par le cerveau humain qui n'emploient
que 10 % de ses ressources font des
milliards de réseau internet ne
suffirait pas pour égaler sa puissance
[Musique]
l'adn de l'homme actuel est quasi
identique à l'adn d'un primate est
pourtant l'intelligence humaine sur
passe énormément les capacités de tout
être vivant ne suivant pas la loi de
l'évolution ce décalage entre les
primates et les êtres humains pose des
questions sur l'origine de l'homme des
fouilles archéologiques fournissent une
réponse étrange sur l'origine de l'homme
les anciens écrits sumériens égyptien
hébreu et du reste du monde disent tous
que le genre humain est le produit d'une
manipulation génétique entre un primate
est des êtres venus de l'espace
[Musique]
l'être humain est un farceur
nous le savons bien
[Applaudissements]
certes on assume avoir visité des
soucoupes volantes sans donner aucune
preuve tangible de l'existence des
extraterrestres nous ton tout de même
que le plus ancien des livres indien le
veda site
400000 race humanoïde existantes dans la
voie lactée dont une douzaine est déjà
venu visiter la terre à maintes reprises
écrit il y a quatre mille ans quand la
technologie arrivait au mieux à fondre
le bronze
le veda cite aussi des vaisseaux
spatiaux appelé vie mana dotés de
moteurs à photons et utilisant la
lumière pour rejoindre des planètes dans
leurs orbites se rapproche
[Musique]
la très jeune terre est l'une des 100
milliards de planètes qui composent la
voie lactée
mais la vie est apparue auparavant
[Musique]
comme l'univers obéit aux mêmes lois
partout dans la création d'autres êtres
humains existent dans le cosmos et son
plus ancien que l'homme ainsi un unique
genre humain d'apparence humanoïdes
vivrait sur plusieurs planètes depuis la
nuit des temps et les plus avancés se
promènerait entre les astres pour
explorer la galaxie c'est ce que la
tradition ésotérique affirme évoquant
une époque vieille 2 milliards d'années
quand un souffle une essence appelé
conscience s'est dispersée dans
l'univers
[Musique]
en animant des formes de vie la
conscience a généré l'espèce humanoïdes
d être mortelle au pouvoir mental créé
et développé
[Musique]
dans notre galaxie la voie lactée la
relation avec la conscience est ressenti
de manière très aigu par lé premier
humanoïde générer ainsi des qu'il
parvienne à une technologie avancée
il s'impose la tâche de rechercher dans
l'espace leur race soeur dans un noble
but de regroupement se dévouant au
partage génétique pour que les uns
atteignent aux facultés des autres ces
humanoïdes forme avec leurs semblables
une union interstellaire lempire
cosmique humain
[Musique]
les composants de l' empire se surnomme
ami et comme unis télépathiquement entre
eux et avec tout être vivant leur
accouchement sont artificielles et
réalisés en laboratoire sans rapports
sexuels d'où le renvoi à la mère vierge
[Musique]
pour réfléchir sur les actions à
accomplir
ils descendent dans de profondes chambre
acoustique creuser sous le sol et d'où
ils utilisent la résonance du son pour
améliorer leurs capacités perceptives
est entré en transe
[Musique]
c'est par des fréquences audio qu'il
manipule la matière et la force de
gravité déplaçant d'énormes pierres et
se mouvant dans l'espace et dans le
temps
le concept du temps est temps lié à
l'espace les amis dispose de techniques
adéquates pour rejoindre le passé le
présent et l'avenir sur plusieurs
endroits de la voie lactée
[Musique]
en ces temps là la terre avec ses
plantes et ses animaux n'a aucune
importance stratégique
l'homme terrestre n'existe pas notre
système solaire est aux marges de la
voie lactée
alors que l' empire cosmique humain est
positionné en son centre
[Musique]
surgit alors un problème grave
les humanoïdes de lempire cherchent
leurs semblables afin de les intégrer
dans une unique conscience mais ne
s'aperçoivent pas tout de suite un autre
genre humanoïdes au contraire aspire à
la destruction de tout être vivant
les premiers amis qui se mélangent
génétiquement à ces êtres nuisibles à
6000 d'ainsi leurs génisses sinistre et
s'infecte
quand l' empire découvre enfin ce projet
destructeur
il déclare la guerre à ces humanoïdes
appelé ennemis en éliminant paris et
bloque génétiquement la contamination
sans pour autant pouvoir en annuler les
effets
désormais les infectés forme d'une
nouvelle race humanoïde à double facette
ami/ennemi mélange des deux rivales
lempire cosmique humain ne les oublie
pas
poursuivant son dessin unificateur il
explore d'autres astres et quand ils
découvrent des ondes guérisseuse sur la
planète berre il y transfère les
humanoïdes de mélanger
[Musique]
ces gens très doués autant que malin
forme les premières civilisations
terrestre lémurie mu et atlantide
[Musique]
mais au fil des millénaires leur
conscience se dégrade toujours plus et
quand ils se révoltent contre l' empire
celui ci décide de les supprimer des
vies des astéroïdes vers la terre et
provoque un désastre qui efface lémurie
mu atlantide et leurs habitants ce
bombardement cause une longue période
d'obscurcissement du ciel sans rayons
solaires
plusieurs forêts se glace et de grands
animaux tels que les dinosaures
s'éteignent
[Musique]
bien qu égard est certes un humanoïde de
survie il se cache dans le sous-sol
terrestre
et quand le désastre se termine ils
rejoignent les terres épargné et grâce à
ce qui reste de leur bagage
technologique
ils reprennent leur vie ainsi il y a
environ 400 mille ans les survivants des
premières civilisations s'éparpille
partout sur la terre et la colonise
bâtissant ses oeuvres monumentales qui
nous émerveille encore
[Musique]
pour la survie de son espèce cette race
utilise l'habituel méthodes de
manipulation génétique elle mélange son
adn à l'adn d'un primate et obtient son
descendant terrestre l'homme actuel
[Musique]
les religieux les scientifiques et ceux
qui suivent la logique ne croient pas un
mot de cette science fiction rené
descartes est l'opposant le plus célèbre
à l'ésotérisme
le bon sens est la chose du monde la
mieux partagée pour les mauvaises
doctrine
je pensais déjà connaître assez ce
qu'elle valait pour n'être plus sujets à
être trompé ni par les promesses d'un
alchimiste ni par les prédictions d'un
astrologue ni par les impostures d'un
magicien ni par les artifices sous la
vente de riz d'aucuns de ceux qui font
profession de savoir plus qu'ils ne
savent
[Musique]
dans son rationalisme des cartes affirme
qu'il y a aucune preuve tangible que le
comté haute eric est vrai mais il n'y a
aucune preuve de tout autre vérité
[Musique]
alors si la vérité est relative
évitez la vérité est peut-être une
solution
[Musique]